[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i can't
[Music]
a little privacy
tinkles i swear
bad thing goes bad no
no no no
ah
don't you have anyone else to play with
wait a second that's it
oh tinkles
i have a little surprise for you
[Music]
oh don't worry what we need
is a monster dog
like lollipop
[Music]
[Music]
say hello
oh booty
[Music]
he's not that weird
okay he's weird what about swampy
[Music]
next diablo
next
spike
pebbles
heidi
slithers sharky
whatever this thing is
next
what the last one oh boy this had better
work
oh
tinkles
great news i found you the perfect
monster pet to play with
say hello to your new best friend
sand
[Music]
oh
it's a cat
stop
[Music]
[Music]
great now who are you going to play with
oh
[Music]
blobby
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
behold the transformation ray awesome
but is this safe though let's find out
huh
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up johnny oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
dad
you're human drag oh no i have a total
dad bod
um what is going on
what's up
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this there
is a place deep in the amazon only there
can the transformations be reversed time
to go
right
human
wow flying his monster is so much better
right
feeling better
nervous liar huh
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious it's wondrous
it's burning my eyes
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever seriously everybody
relax
just enjoy the view ah please
being a human is the worst and swim
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun hey track what's up
johnny
yeah it's me
i'm a monster
what is going on demonstration ray turns
humans into monsters and monsters into
humans
the nightmare it's over i'm human again
hmm
[Music]
you're a human and i'm a monster
we need to fix this now not the moment
away
[Music]
what's up fellas
[Applause]
[Music]
you